[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight every president since George
Washington has faced political
opposition every single one of them and
that's the point of our system
democracies are built on debate and
competing ideas if you find a political
leader who seems universally loved what
she found is a dictatorship
nobody criticized Ceausescu nobody dared
so as a matter of principle there is
nothing wrong with the posing Donald
Trump in his policies dissent is
patriotic but that's not what has been
happening for the past two-and-a-half
years nothing about the resistance has
enhanced our democracy or made this
country better just the opposite
the left's opposition to Trump has
shredded democratic norms since the
moment the last ballot was cast in 2016
they have worked to nullify the
presidential election they've imposed
censorship on much of the country and
more than anything they've sided with
the permanent bureaucracy over voters
people like former CIA director John
Brennan have openly urged federal
employees to ignore and undermine the
elected president that is a brazen
attack on democracy it's more
destructive than anything the Russians
attempted Brennan now delivers his
instructions from a desk at NBC News
where he's paid to deliver commentary
like this this is nothing short of
treasonous because it is a betrayal of
the nation he is giving aid and comfort
to the enemy treasonous is defined as a
betrayal of trust as well as aiding
abetting the enemy and so that was the
word that came to my mind yeah so when
you disagree with John Brennan former
head of the CIA it is high treason
it's a death-penalty offense that's the
case he's making John Brennan is a
reckless and unbalanced partisan that's
obvious to anyone who's watched him when
we learned from the source last year
that Brennan had somehow retained his
top-secret security clearance as a
civilian we were shocked but we weren't
really surprised
that's how Washington actually works
Brennan no longer works for the federal
government in any capacity he holds no
official post and yet according to two
sources we spoke to exclusively today
Brennan retains perhaps the most
valuable asset he had
government a top-secret security
clearance it is terrifying to think that
John Brennan still has access to any of
that information Brennan is an out of
the closet extremists this is not a man
who should have security clearance many
in Congress agreed with that assessment
Senator Rand Paul of Kentucky came on
this show to say that John Brennan had
no business holding a security clearance
shortly after that segment aired the
president announced that he was revoking
Brennan's clearance we assumed that was
the end of the story and in a real
democracy it would have been but it
wasn't because this isn't so year later
we learned that Brennan still has a
security clearance
how did that happen because executive
branch officials simply ignored the
president's orders this is a problem
because he was elected by voters and
they were not all legitimate power in
the executive branch flows from him and
the election that he won but his
employees don't care increasingly
bureaucrats wield the real authority in
this country you see it every day in
Washington but this one time we decided
to find out exactly what happened the
first thing we did was we called over to
the executive branch we were told that
John Brennan no longer has quote access
to classified information a source
explained to us that means the
administration sent a letter to
intelligence agencies explain that
Brennan no longer has a quote need to
know that all sounds reassuring it had a
kind of narcotic effect but like so much
that happens in government it's a mirage
it means nothing
in fact bureaucrats didn't simply ignore
that letter if they choose they have
before so the truth is the president
knighted States was undermined by his
own staff he gave them a direct
unequivocal order in their feline
passive-aggressive way they refused to
carry it out how many times a day does
that happen every time it does our
democracy erodes by the way that's fine
with official Washington if holding
elections means that Donald Trump wins
power they're against elections whatever
it takes including brute force just the
other day Nancy Pelosi told Democrats on
Capitol Hill her goal isn't to impeach
the president her goal is to put him in
prison for what crime she didn't specify
but it doesn't matter you know as well
as anyone
that trumps real offense was getting
elected in the first place